the Pythagoras theorem is pretty simple
to understand and fortunately a very
important topic to it deals only with
right triangles like this one let the
lengths of its sides be a B and C in
this triangle a squared plus B squared
will equal C squared this right here is
called the Pythagoras theorem the side
opposite the right angle is called the
hypotenuse the square of the hypotenuse
is always equal to the sum of the
squares of the other two sides what kind
of problems would we come across in our
exams we might be given a triangle with
the lengths of two of its sides and one
unknown and using the Pythagoras theorem
we can easily find the length of that
side the unknown here is the hypotenuse
so 3 squared plus 4 squared will equal x
squared solving this we get the value of
x as five units another example would be
a right triangle like this with sides 5y
and 13
using the pythagoras theorem in this one
we can write v squared plus y squared
equals 13 squared and solving this we
get the value of y as 12 these examples
were pretty easy to solve but these two
examples also tell us something very
interesting 3 4 & 5
form up Pythagorean triple a Pythagorean
triple consists of three positive
integers in which the sum of squares of
two numbers is equal to the square of
the third in a similar way five 12 and
13 also form a Pythagorean triple these
are two very commonly used by theory and
triples but there's something even more
special here if we multiply each of
these numbers by 2 we get 6 8 and
and this too will be a Pythagorean
triple even if we multiply each of these
numbers by three we get a Pythagorean
triple nine twelve and fifteen if we
multiply each of these by two then ten
24 and 26 also form a Pythagorean triple
so in your exam if you are given a right
triangle with the perpendicular sides as
nine and twelve you don't really have to
solve anything you should know that it's
15 if you have the hypotenuse as 26 and
one side is 10 the third side has to be
24 but we need to be a little careful
here let's say we have a triangle like
this with sides 3 4 and X and we are
asked to find the value of x do not
assume X to be 5 units yes we know it is
a Pythagorean triple but here we haven't
be told that the triangle is
right-angled X will be equal to 5 units
only if the measure of angle B is 90
degrees